today's episode is sponsored by Honey
the easy way to save when you're
shopping on your iPhone or computer I
mean you know I feel great when I find a
deal I feel very smart I feel lucky I
feel excited you know when I'm surprised
by a deal I feel like I'm getting a
treat for free thanks to Honey manually
searching for coupon codes there's a
thing of the past Honey's the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies to best one
you know because you don't want to be
the person with the clipping of the
coupons you know I had relatives that
would do that they would clip coupons
and then they would go to the grocery
store and then they would you know buy
things with the coupons and now on the
internet there's a version of that where
you're just looking for promo codes all
day but then you know you don't want to
be that person but what honey does is
they scour the thing so you don't have
to
okay imagine you're shopping at one of
your favorite sites when you check out
the honey button appears and all you
have to do is Click apply coupons wait a
few seconds as honey searches for
coupons it can find for that site if
honey finds a working coupon you'll
watch the prices drop I just started
using it it saved me money okay I love
it
I mean you know
honey saves me I was ordering clothes
the other day on the internet and then
honey had a coupon and it saved me money
it was great I loved it honey doesn't
just work on desktops it works on your
iPhone too just activated on Safari on
your phone and save on the go if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight at missing out and by getting
it you'll be doing yourself a solid and
supporting this show get PayPal honey
for free joinhoney.com d That's join
honey.com slash Tim D
tomorrow Monterey California Friday
Vancouver Canada Saturday Napa
California March through the 9th through
the 11th I'll be in Palm Beach Florida
our rescheduled Raleigh day to 24 4th
and the 25th in Raleigh North Carolina
Thursday April 13th Inglewood New Jersey
Friday April 14th Huntington New York
Saturday April 15th New Brunswick New
Jersey Sunday April 16th Huntington New
York we also have shows being announced
at places like Tacoma and Portland and
San Francisco very very soon enjoy the
episode ladies and gentlemen welcome to
the Tim Dillon show we are going to be a
Monday show we are uploading uh today
Tuesday uh because we got back late from
Arizona where we did a bunch of shows
sold them out in Phoenix and Tucson I
think Tucson was sold out we were close
um thanks to everybody who came out it
was a lot of fun I I spent almost a week
there in the desert and uh I like
Arizona I like it because it's a state
that is evenly divided between uh
retirees and Psychopaths
um those are the two largest demographic
groups in Arizona people that are
retired and people who are psychotic and
that's a fun mix because there's one
side constantly trying to drag some of
the people into their side like the
Psychopaths they get a few of the
retirees to come on to their side they
pull them it's like that thing in gym
where you tug a war and you try to pull
people uh and the Psychopaths
occasionally will pull some of the
retirees and then some of the retirees
will pull some of the Psychopaths and
just be like hey man how about just
chill how about just [__] swing a
golf club
um but it's that natural tension between
retiree and psychopath which is what the
desert is that's the whole desert but it
was a lot of fun there we enjoyed
ourselves we are now the official
podcast sponsor of the Ukraine war this
is something that I'm very excited about
we beat out
um a lot of the other podcasts we beat
out my favorite murder we beat that last
podcast on the left we beat out uh the
girls got to eat dude the girls that
sling the vibrators uh we beat them uh
to be the official sponsor of the
Ukraine war we are the show that
sponsors the Ukraine war as a podcast
now that doesn't mean we wanted to keep
going just because we are these official
sponsor of the Ukraine war we don't want
it to keep going however
as long as it does keep going uh we do
realize that war can be beautiful and
teach us beautiful things about
ourselves and the world around us
um and that makes us the official
sponsor of uh the Ukraine war as a
podcast
uh similar to America who's sponsoring
the Ukraine war but doesn't want it to
keep going but if it does if it happens
to uh it should be
um beautiful our president remember when
this started a year ago the Ukraine war
remember about a year ago the Ukraine
war started Russia invaded the Ukraine
and the idea was that there would be
some type of
push for peace that this would end or
someone would want this to end
um
and that has not been the case we are
now a year in
and uh you know now we're saying like
Biden's gone out and said like Russia
will never win in Ukraine so it's the
American position that Russia has to
lose which is
uh I understand why that's the Ukrainian
position but it's the American position
now that Russia has to lose which is
different from the American position
saying we would like peace
peace would mean or you would think it
would mean that both countries made some
arrangement agreement and that the
fighting War would cease
um there'd be a treaty we know it how
this works
but now President Biden has come out and
said uh there will be no victory for
Russia in Ukraine Russia will never win
which of course means that Russia will
lose and then he made a surprise visit
to the capital
uh on Monday and he was like it was very
secretive and sexy and because the whole
thing with Biden now is because he's old
and he's kind of enfeebled and he he
doesn't know how to speak they have to
dress him up as he's like a tough guy
and he's tough and it's like he doesn't
give a [__] and you know look at him
walking next to Solinski and you know
it's like Mr Biden arrived early Monday
morning to meet with President zielinski
this is the New York Times after a
10-hour overnight train ride which he
slept through probably
um but the two stepped out into the
streets of Kiev even as an air raid
siren sounded a dramatic moment that
underscored the investment the United
States has made in the Ukraine's
independence by the way it's clear they
want Biden dead like the people
like the people that are worried that he
may not be a good candidate they're like
yeah yeah you go over there show your
support walk around in the street you
and zelinsky make out whatever you have
to do make sure you're into public make
sure you see a bunch of people
um Biden was there for only five hours
uh and he promised to release another
500 million in military aid in coming
days
500 million uh dollars
now the Ukraine wants some real deal
arms because Ukraine is now saying we
want to go into Red Square we want to
push into Russia you know we want to
bring down the regime in Russia uh
Russia is now pulled out of a nuclear
proliferation treaty uh with us symbolic
for sure who knows not the treaties keep
people from doing anything they want to
do anyway
um but you know this is It's become a uh
incredibly and it's sad that anybody is
dying right so we all feel bad for any
civilian in the Ukraine that has been
killed anybody in Russia that has been
drafted in to go fight this war we feel
bad for anybody that's life is being
thrown into the abyss you're throwing
these people's lives uh into this black
hole
um but
you know
now now we are basically saying like
we're in
we like it we like it the idea that we
don't like the Ukraine war
has to be destroyed we love it
we have a war of white people
in which we can throw hundreds of
billions
maybe more at we enjoy it we like it
it's good for the weapons industry it's
good for our uh by the way what else are
we going to talk about the trains that
keep derailing with the poison we don't
want to do that
we're going to talk about the kids in
Ohio who are being refused lunch we're
going to talk about that later but what
do we what do we really have to say
we like talking about the Ukraine war
it's good for our country to take the
focus off of the things that we don't
really love about what's happening in
our country and put it on the Ukraine
um
and we kind of like it's a it's a fun
Pastime right now it's like sports the
Super Bowl's over so this is kind of the
new thing this is another article here
uh in the New York Times which the New
York Times is now the official like U.S
prom it's always been but like
specifically for this war
um very exciting very exciting here not
peace mind you not steps towards peace
um in the in the New York Times some of
the best weapons in the world are now in
Ukraine they may change the war
so we're now celebrating the Weaponry
that we send not not any steps towards
any type of agreement that would stop
fighting
tens of billions of dollars of weapons
have flowed from Europe and North
American countries into the Ukraine
rifles bullets missiles artillery
yeah baby
at first the Nations insisted that the
weapons were defensive designed to help
the Ukraine fight off The Invasion one
year later as The Battered but still
potent Russian military prepares for a
renewed offensive the type of weapons
heading into Ukraine have changed
dramatically now they're getting the
good stuff now they're getting the stuff
that they've kind of always wanted the
distinction my my favorite uh line here
the distinction between offensive and
defensive weapons was always a little
bit arbitrary
it's a little bit arbitrary it doesn't
really matter what we're giving them are
we giving them things to defend
themselves or to keep this going or to
push in to expand the scope of the war
we don't know we're just giving them fun
stuff and they're having fun and that's
just good old-fashioned American uh
money laundering uh slush fund uh you
know Empire building stuff this is what
we do
um
and uh you know
I'm just uh you know it's it's
unfortunate we're we're um we're
enjoying this though and we're we're
enjoying it a little too much
it's a little scary how much we're
liking it
um it's it's Biden's you know he's
allowing him to seem strapping and cool
remember Boris Johnson in the UK did
this when he went to visit with I'm
sorry when he went to visit with
zelinski if you were an embattled leader
in your country you just visit
zielinski and you walk around
kiev for a few hours and it's a nice
boost it's a boost to the numbers I
think by the way people army hammers
should do that why are celebrities not
doing that why are celebrities why don't
canceled celebrities visit Keith
get Harvey Weinstein out of jail have
him walk next to zielinski down a main
street in Kiev Kiev whatever and I think
you could be looking at a good boost in
numbers
Bill Cosby's on tour I've got his first
tour date Keith
this is how much we love the war how
much we're enjoying it we have an
article in the New Yorker can
psychedelics heal ukrainians drama
so we're basically like let's not end
the trauma let's not end it
micro dose mushrooms
take some psychedelics get a shaman take
some Ayahuasca it'll be like the war's
not even happening you can
therapeutically cleanse yourself of War
we're not going to stop the actual War
but you can feel better about the war
with a nice psychedelic regimen
meanwhile in New York Ukrainian
delegation including a representative
for the territorial Defense Forces had
gathered to consider types of Aid other
types of Aid the goal according to an ad
for the event was to promote the
psychological and spiritual resilience
of Ukrainian people living in trauma
crisis and War
it's a psychological resilience we're
promoting your it's tough we know it's
tough
we know it's tough and we know that we
could maybe in a way kind of push for
some type of peace talks but we're not
going to do that we're not gonna stop
this war in fact we're going to pour
gasoline we are now pouring gasoline on
this it's wrong that Putin invaded all
war is terrible but the idea that we
want this to stop is kind of hilarious
and now we're basically telling
ukrainians you better get Dr you better
use drugs because we're not ending this
[__] so you better start using
psychedelic drugs uh you know whatever
it is here's great demetriev whoever
this guy is kick things off by telling
this group okay through a translator
that he hopes to train 1500 Military
chaplains in special spiritual
resilience program
so the new plan for the Ukraine war is
to have the chaplains act as shamans and
guide people
through microdosing in Ayahuasca so they
can feel better about this war
um so they can work through their trial
and I'm not saying psychedelics don't
have
um a place in in therapy of trauma
here's what also is really good in terms
of therapy and Trauma
stopping the trauma
stopping the trauma not spending
billions of dollars to keep the trauma
going
that helps as well
yes stitches can help wounds also not
throwing a kid off a [__] roof like
there's there's other ways to calm this
[__] thing down
but as the official sponsor of uh the
Ukraine uh War we like we we like the
idea that
we are participating in a very confusing
uh battle where there are no real clear
objectives
and very little
identifiable National interest so we can
just kind of rev this baby rev it up Let
It Go 20 years a 20-year
uh War here would be our best case
scenario a 20-year war that bleeds
Russia dry
foreign
now here's the other thing I want to get
into because I I mean you know the
Ukraine will check in on it every now
and then it's the year anniversary
congrats but we're not going to we we
can't you know it can't be all Ukraine
all the time even though we are the
official sponsor of the Ukraine war and
we'll continue to be and we will provide
uh people in the Ukraine uh with
whatever they need whether it be uh uh
shroom tea or whatever helps them deal
with the uh bombings that uh our money
and support uh guarantees will not end
also uh China is now stepping in so
China our favorite country China my
godson uh uh China's president Xi
Jinping
um he's going to Chinese leaders
expected to use Moscow trip to push for
multi-party peace talks so China is
actually uh thank God someone's running
the world China is now stepping up to uh
do a peace treaty in the Ukraine China
is stepping up to do it whereas America
uh we are you know proceeding with the
Ayahuasca uh Retreats
um Beijing says it wants to play a more
active role aimed at ending the conflict
boo
maybe they're not going to end it either
I don't know I'm not going to take them
at their word for it maybe nobody wants
attend and the people familiar with
aji's trip planned a set of meeting with
Mr Putin would be a part of the push
right nobody wants this war to end
I have a bit about it on stage I don't
really want it to end nobody wants it to
end I'm sorry we can't have an end now
we're in it
it's just a good pillar of the news
nobody wants it to end it's
accomplishing a lot of things for a lot
of people there's a lot of people with
financial interest in this we can have
it end we don't want any nukes because
that's mean but what we want is just a
prolonged conflict there this is not
something anyone wants to stop I'm
telling you nobody wants I don't think
China wants to stop this either maybe
they do maybe maybe
now what are these people whining now
about here's the deal with climate
change we're all dealing with it in our
own way it's been freezing in Los
Angeles the winds are insane everybody's
upset
why are these people in Palestine Ohio
getting all of the attention
everybody's dealing with this every
single group of people in America is
dealing with this my friend who had a
beautiful Waterfront in Florida it's
like down to the studs now now of course
you wanted to do a renovation anyway it
kind of comes in handy and she has a
place up in the Hudson Valley she can go
the point is she's dealing with a
horrible situation in Florida where she
has to renovate her house
um because it was just destroyed so
these people in East Palestine Ohio
uh that are complaining about this
trained derailment constantly I don't
understand why they're sucking up all
the oxygen and that I'm not trying to do
a pun
um I don't get it I don't get what the
big deal is a train crashed with some
chemicals and now you have some
headaches and you're itchy
what's the big deal
this puts you on the map
EPA Chief Ohio governor drink tap water
near train derailment site after heavy
what's the they're drinking it
what's the problem
I'm sick of these people just because oh
the sky is full of black smoke and oh I
have a horrible headache I can't sleep
I'm inching my kids are screaming
there's no more shared sacrifice anymore
okay 11 cars carrying toxic chemicals
whatever derailed as a train passed
through the town on the Ohio
Pennsylvania border officials conducted
a controlled burn of this build
chemicals to prevent an explosion
they're trying to help you
um releasing large plumes of dangerous
chemicals into the air that left foul
smells in the area and has reportedly
made livestock and pets sick
um
I think the people here are overreacting
um I knew people a lot of people that
went down to Ground Zero
and uh breathed the air in at Ground
Zero and some of them are alive
so I just think that like I understand
people being upset but you really you
have to look at is this just do you just
want attention
is that really what it is is it like oh
no one's ever talked about Palestine
Ohio
and this is the time for now people to
just get a chance where can you are
there like some type oh look at that
that looks can we bring that up
this looks not bad this is from what
space
this is not even a big deal this thing
this is a small
train derailment with 11 cars with a few
toxic chemicals a control burn in the
air that's uh giving people
um headaches for days they can't sleep
uh and their pets are dying but other
than that I don't see a huge problem
here and I think really this is just
again a bunch of people in the middle of
Ohio that want to go Hollywood
this is the this is a culture of reality
TV freaks who want attention do we have
any of the uh people like are there any
of the citizens of Ohio can we hear from
them are they
I mean can we at least like hear why um
this is being dominating the news cycle
constantly
and I'm unable to understand why this is
getting more pressed in an incredibly
freezing cold winter in Los Angeles that
is forcing me and several of my friends
indoors when many of the houses are
built for indoor outdoor living many of
them are built literally for indoor
outdoor living where you have a a pane
of glass separating the inside and the
outside
I don't even understand and all I hear
about is is this it's uh Palestine Ohio
uh the train we're mad uh the people in
Ohio are mad their pets have headaches
it's like guys can we please
you have to enjoy it
stop being paranoid about everything
it's just 11 cars of toxic chemicals you
know I think that it's a bunch of people
being babies
it's a bunch of big babies just get out
there throw a frisbee
get out there and move get out there get
your steps in you know these people
aren't lying they're not gonna lie you
think they would tell you that water was
okay to drink if it wasn't do you
believe the government would do that do
you think they would tell you that the
air was okay to breathe just so that you
wouldn't it wouldn't be mass panic do
you think they would lie to you just
said they wouldn't be mass panic and
then years later when many of you pop up
with a weird illnesses that can't be
traced to anything except the fact that
you all lived in these Palestine Ohio
during the train derailment uh do you
think that is like realistic that sounds
like a movie
that doesn't sound like something that
would actually happen like you know five
years from now when people can't breathe
and people just you know in the middle
of the night start uh expiring uh yeah I
mean that sounds like a movie I think
that it is safe I think it's okay I
don't think it's a big deal
I think it's cool as [__] actually
the amount of [__] photos and [__]
cool [__] now happening in your
community where nothing has ever
happened no one's ever heard of this
place and now it's cage getting all the
[__] attention
the tick tocks coming out of there
people getting noticed for the first
goddamn time
be a chemical spill influencer like use
this to get yourself on track to making
people know who you are if you're a
reasonably good looking person in East
Palestine Ohio get out there and start
dancing in front of the smoke
and I'm telling you this is your don't
let this pass you by
when Parkland happened
those kids got famous Greta thundberg's
been famous right you need to be if if
there is a young climate activist this
is your time right now your time to
recognize you don't have to go to
college uh or if you do it can get paid
for you don't have to have a shitty job
you can get out there and make this your
brand I mean I'm telling you the media
will eat it up they'll Eat You Alive
um just do it you know people are
complaining about uh headaches chest
tightness eye pain this is a 28 year old
told BuzzFeed news
you know a lot I'd say it's anxiety you
have anxiety this is what this town has
they have anxiety this isn't real this
isn't something that's happening to you
just because of the uh toxic uh burn
control burn of the chemicals this is at
your anxious and you're nervous because
you're getting your moment in the
National spot like you don't you wonder
if you measure up
and you might not but that's really what
it is like you are anxious and it's sad
but I I don't think we have to go and
and oh the worst cloth I've had
shortness of breath and the worst cough
I've ever had in my life
drama queen
will you stop
what is this the long coveted crowd now
because the train flipped over
enough nearly one million pounds of
vinyl chloride were on this train now
the EPA has confirmed it's entered the
Ohio River Basin which is home to 25
million what's wrong with vinyl chloride
this is one of the deadliest
environmental emergencies in decades and
no one is talking about it
vital chloride is not only flammable
but it's also brain lung blood and liver
carcinogen authorities decided to burn
hundreds of thousands of gallons of this
chemical after a trained derailment in
East Palestine Ohio
well what could have happened they said
is if it would exploded it would have
sent shrapnel for a mile
one mile and you would have been like
sitting in a chair and then
it would have been like Final
Destination so what they did was they
decided to burn off the chemicals in
like a controlled burn
and then tell everyone that it's just
chill
you know and I think that that's the
problem right now
is people are not acting chill
pretend that nothing's happening
you're suffering from anxiety I don't
think people are complaining about the
smell too they're saying the smell is
like a mix of super glue and bleach but
it has a bit of sweetness
focus on the sweetness
glass half full
that'd be worse it could be like the
kids in Ohio I I was reading about these
school lunches and apparently I don't
understand this
um during covid apparently people in
Ohio were given a free lunch for the
kids kids were able to eat food for free
and now they are not the school lunch
program in Ohio is ending uh and that
means that people get a pay I think it's
two or three dollars a day
um uh for
two dollars I mean it's two dollars a
day per child okay but some parents are
struggling and they don't have that
um and so
basically they're coming out and saying
they're taking I'm not even kidding this
is not even a joke they are taking the
trays from the children who cannot pay
they are taking the food back from the
kids uh quote that was a little
heartbreaking for my staff to deny
children and take the tray away
they are taking the tray away from
children in Ohio
and they are giving billions of dollars
to the Ukraine for weapons so just
process all that in your head
um
now I'm trying to think if there's any
reason someone would be against a school
lunch because I know that
like a free school lunch because I know
that that is kind of an issue that
people debate and I know that it's kind
of a contentious issue I could see you
know my father said to me once a hungry
dog runs the farthest
and I'm so I'm thinking now is that
potentially the thinking there like you
know sometimes it's good to motivate a
kid so when the kids come into the
lunchroom and they all have their
lunches and they're all eating and one
kid
uh or a few can't afford the lunch and
they go to grab the tray and you take it
from them and go no it's not yours and
then they have to sit there their blood
sugar drops and they kind of get
listless and they're upset does that
motivate them to like go home and learn
about the stock market I don't know that
is a good question like what is why
can't we just make food for all of the
kids you'd think that we could just have
enough money to make a lunch that would
feed all of the children
but maybe there is a reason that some of
the children shouldn't eat
and that's something that I think we do
have to explore
number one kids are fat
so maybe they're just denying the fat
kids food
which I think helps if they maybe if
they just sat all the fat kids in it or
maybe the fat kids uh made them like
work out during lunch so when all the
other kids are given food the fat kids
maybe they're putting a a side of the uh
you know uh cafeteria and they're made
to
um you know I don't know jump around but
um I I don't I'm trying to think of what
what would be a good reason to not pay
for maybe the kids if the K will it
teach them to not work hard if we keep
giving them like a free two dollar lunch
a day like if we give them ziti or we
give them the hot dog does that just
create complacency where they're unable
to function
I don't know
what I also found is that children who
come to school late they end up in panic
mode worried to death they're not going
to get their breakfast because they
missed it and the doors closed a lot of
people now don't eat breakfast at home
um a lot of people wake up this is what
happens and I don't know where in Ohio
this is but this is oh this this is for
all of Ohio the the thing that's being
discussed is for all of Ohio
um but a lot of times people wake up now
and they see their mother is like
drinking you know she's like drunk and
she's in a house dress and she's
wandering around and uh uh she's not
like cooking eggs for them and their
father's dead or missing
and so it's a kid like that who like
wakes up Mom's drunk already she's like
laughing to herself at the table looking
at old pictures
and she's coming in and out of laughing
and crying
and then the kid is like hi Mom I love
you and then gives her a kiss on the
head and she's like look at you when you
were a baby and she's crying and
laughing and she's kind of rocking like
sometimes they Rock back and forth at
the table like this or maybe she's not
saying anything maybe the kid wakes up
and he walks downstairs into the kitchen
and the mother's just kind of like
rocking back and forth and then the
father is maybe out uh tilling the land
he's telling the land or maybe he's uh
Dead uh or maybe he's I don't know you
know doing something else so the kids
now they don't have the breakfast right
they're not able to it's not like people
you know we grow up with those 1950s
commercials where like a mom is making
eggs or making pancakes but that's not
true or like Mom sometimes is working
now like sometimes kids wake up and the
house is empty because the parents are
at work right so then the kids aren't
gonna go home I mean they're not gonna
go downstairs
and fend for themselves uh they need to
go and get a breakfast at school but a
lot of people are against that
and
and I I don't I mean there might be a
good reason for it why a kid shouldn't
have a breakfast in school
maybe maybe they should figure it out I
don't know I'm I'm I'm in the middle on
this I'm undecided should children eat
you know what I mean like this is a good
question I don't think it's as easy it's
I don't think it's as easy as people
make it out to be people just go oh yeah
we have the money feed them
yeah but hold on a minute you know I
don't know if that's a good idea I know
that for example lunch eating lunch for
me uh ruined a lot of opportunities for
me because we would eat in mortgages we
would eat such a big lunch
that uh many of us would fall asleep in
our chair or go into that state where
you're kind of asleep uh because you've
had so much uh carbohydrates or sugar
you're kind of like checking in and out
and maybe that's the problem here is
that we need to have kids kind of being
like on a fast and healthy but um
I'm unsure I I welcome anybody that's
had experience with this the pro-hungry
children and people that are anti-hungry
children I I appreciate like a debate
either either way it's um
we need stronger kids healthier kids and
I don't know if that requires feeding
them or not feeding them that's a
question you know I love bespoke posts
because if you take the quiz at
boxofawesome.com what you're doing is
giving somebody a gift that keeps on
giving they get a box every single month
with a bunch of cool stuff in it
tailored to their own interests and
things they like each box is valued at
around seventy dollars but you pay a
fraction of that price all of the things
in these boxes it could be like camping
stuff or things to make cocktails or
things to grill any cool stuff for
personal grooming or at being an
Outdoorsman again it's whatever you like
or an outdoors lady
um
box of awesome you're supporting small
businesses because all of these things
in these boxes come from small
businesses 90 of everything comes from a
small up and coming brand really in
America and it's free to sign up you can
skip a month or cancel any time it's
great for anybody going away moving to a
new city going to college you want them
to think about you throughout the year
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up a box of awesome.com enter
the code Tim Dillon at checkout that's
box of awesome.com code Tim Dillon for
20 off your first box box of awesome.com
code Tim Dylan
I love these beds everyone asks me what
are the beds you have uh in your Long
Island House they're so cool I'm like
they're Helix and everybody goes really
and I go yeah Helix is amazing okay I'm
telling you right now I I have a lot of
beds I've spent a lot more money on beds
and people like the Helix beds better
than the other more expensive beds and
so do I
um I love Helix you just take a you know
quiz you take a quiz
how do you sleep What's your deal do you
like a hot sleeper cold sleeper you side
back stomach you sleep like a bat like
you know like hide you something and
hanging I don't know but whatever it is
Helix is gonna find the right mattress
for you right they have everything for
all kinds of different sleepers I mean
I'm telling you right now you take the
Helix sleep quiz and find your perfect
mattress in under two minutes and your
personalized mattress is shipped
straight to your door free of charge
Helix knows there's no better way to
test out a new mattress than by sleeping
on it in your own home that's why
there's a hundred night trial and a 10
to 15 year warranty to try out your new
Helix mattresses they are confident in
the product it is a good product we
advertise a lot of stuff on the show
um and I try to use as much of it as I
can Helix is something we actually use
everybody likes these beds there's
nobody that is uncomfortable or anything
with these beds so go to helixsleep.com
timd that's helixsleep.com timd and I'm
telling you right now you will not
regret it I personally endorse all of
these
mattresses and everyone I know really
does too and everybody loves them so
helixsleep.com Tim day you know these
residents of these policy is it
Palestine Palestinian Palestine
Palestine Palestine Palestine Ohio
the residents of Palestine Ohio in my
estimation are being a little dramatic
and they are being ungrateful uh for the
government
um because like I said the uh
the the EPA people like that have came
down to Palestine Ohio and they've drank
uh uh a glass of water that they're
claiming is from uh you know the water
system it was probably Fiji but even
still even performatively I think that's
a nice thing to do I think it's a nice
thing to do and there's just a lot of
whining and now people are saying that
uh you know it's the vinyl chloride and
I'm having headaches and a lot of it to
be honest with you it's bad diet a lot
of these headaches are bad diet it's
high sugar high carbs watch does Joe
Rogan Experience uh you need to switch
to a carnivore keto diet because a lot
of these people in Palestine Ohio are
you know high on sugar all day and these
are the headaches because you're coming
down off sugar and this is really bad so
I think it's primarily diet related a
lot of what they're experiencing I think
it's maybe anxiety and I think it's
maybe stress
I don't think it has anything to do with
all the vinyl chloride Burning Up the
Sky I think that's such a jump it's such
a jump to make like just because a train
11 train cars full of vinyl chloride
exploded in your town that's the reason
you're itching it's such a jump when we
know Dairy
is inflammatory it's hugely inflammatory
people get rashes all the time with
dairy when I was a kid I would get
rashes with ketchup and I love ketchup
and I eat it all the time and I
shouldn't it's liquid sugar paste but
it's so good but it gives you rashes you
can get some people get rosacea from
nightshades which is like eggplant
tomatoes and such
things of that nature so what you're
seeing here I believe that Tim Dillon
show believes you're seeing diet related
illnesses in in East Palestinian
Palestine Palestine Palos Verdes
wherever it is I see diet related
illnesses in Ohio being wrongfully
attributed to the 11 train cars full of
the vinyl chloride burning up the
atmosphere
um let's hear what some of these
ungrateful dramatic
truly horrible people have to say about
the things they're supposedly
experiencing all lies these are all lies
so I thought I wasn't sure if I if I was
really smelling what I was smelling and
feeling the way I was feeling
um and then less than five to ten
minutes after I started smelling it my
son woke up out of a dead sleep
violently shaking throwing up totally
disoriented begging for water
um and he was not sick at all like he he
just wasn't there was no no indications
of a sickness before this and it was
shortly just a few minutes after I
started smelling it so at that point I
took them there kids have nightmares I
mean is this woman new kids have
nightmares they wake up often violently
shaking and projectile vomiting sort of
like an exorcist scene because maybe
they're having a nightmare about you
know not winning the big game at the
school and getting the girl this is what
you know or it's the boogeyman's chasing
them through the cornfield these are
common nightmares that kids have and a
lot of them react to this with violent
shaking uh projectile vomiting bleeding
from the eyes
a lot of people have nightmares and they
bleed from their eyes so this woman is
trying to conflate these two unrelated
things her son middle of the night doing
an exorcist
and the 11 cars of vinyl chloride
burning up the sky and uh the rivers and
the oceans and the lakes and the air and
the dogs and the cats and the birds of
the bees and everybody getting you know
so really it's the conflation of two
completely unrelated things the small
chemical
Armageddon and her son waking up in the
middle of the night like Linda Blair
let's let's see someone else because I
Feel Like This Woman's a liar and I
don't like liars
let's see what else we have
this looks like a fun crew however since
I feel like the 9th of February February
yeah
um and were any of you all home when it
happened as well or I actually was home
I jumped out of bed unlike him we didn't
think we were getting evacuate and we
all stood back there and watched it I
texted her and she's like I'm staying
here no problem and then finally they
knocked on her door and forced her out
of bed well I don't know at the area
we've had a lot of suicides with the
rain the railroad tracks there's a lot
so that's my first thought was who hit
the train now like I wasn't thinking
like chemical warfare here so that's my
thought she's like dude it's exploding
so yeah my uh my initial thought I was
downtown I was walking and I thought it
was weird the train I mean the trains
stopped over the intersection from time
to time I just hopped through them when
I were at this corner on the Clark
Street you could see the Flames up in
there and I work at that building right
down there yep so I thought my shop was
on fire so I went running up there to
check on the Kiln and check on
everything back end of our building
caught fire so I actually for some
reason stood out there and watched it
for about 20 minutes like probably for
me to you do it right because like you
said we didn't know what it was right
and are you all back uh back working in
there is the debt building damage oh
yeah they as soon as the evacuation
lifted they were back in work of course
back to work I like it back to work this
is good
that's America you'll watch the
explosion you get a nice little break
it's a nice little break but then you're
back to work you can't use this as some
lazy excuse to not go to work just
because you now have a permanent
headache you have to get back to work
work helps you and people don't realize
this that is uh you know that that you
know there's so much anti-work sentiment
in America all the time now
um like oh children shouldn't work it's
child labor or elderly people shouldn't
work there's no that's not dignified and
they're they're old and we should care
for them they shouldn't work and uh
disabled people shouldn't work and
people with stage four cancer shouldn't
work there's always this cut like
rigmarole like oh they shouldn't work it
shouldn't work uh let's figure it out oh
they shouldn't work oh she has a brain
tumor in two months to live she
shouldn't work it's like really work
actually takes your mind off these
things and it's actually nice so what's
encouraging to me is that while the
smoke is still in the air these people
are back at their jobs because that's
really the ticket to the train so to
speak that leaves them out of this
situation this woman is now what is she
complaining about her father and her
boyfriend Chris after being a vacuum a
complainer came back home today in this
town but she says she broke out in a
rash almost instantly I undressed to get
into the shower and I had a rash all
over the side of my face on both sides
and Oliver my chest take a look at these
photos of her this morning after coming
back on her property the rash all over
her face neck and chest my boyfriend
Chris also had a rash down his left side
and I mean to this moment right now I
have just a really low grade constant
headache they live nearly a mile from
the derailment well they shouldn't be
seeing each other naked if they're
unmarried that's a huge problem right
now is a cohabitation outside of the
bond of marriage I'll hear nothing of
what they have to say my point about
this whole thing is it's been it's been
completely
mismanaged uh by uh like you know all of
the uh the the government really needs
to go and tell these people and they are
but the government needs to not only
tell these people they're fine this is
actually a good thing it's actually a
positive thing so the government has
really failed we're losing the
propaganda War it's called Soft power
meaning that it's not only you know
about you know military uh Power in
America it's about propaganda and it's
about the war of ideas and it's about
information we've heard all of this
that's not only foreign policy it's
domestic too the government needs to
show all these people how lucky they are
to live in a country where chemicals are
so prevalent that occasionally they
spill
think of the loveliness of living in a
land where you can get all the chemicals
you walked
there's so many chemicals that
occasionally
they topple over and no one's concerned
about how much they've lost
they're just complaining about their
bleeding eyes and skin falling off their
face what they should be focused on is
how abundant this Vinyl chloride is how
much of it how easily it is to
synthesize how we can make more and more
of it and and that's really the the
answer here is like thank you God that I
live in a country with all the chemicals
I could ever want on a choo-choo train
going through my backyard how lucky am I
how many people live in places where
they are literally they cannot get
anything they can't get anything ever
in America there is so much vinyl
chloride that no matter when you need it
what if and this seems like weird to say
and I know people are going to ridicule
me what if some of the people in this
town needed Vinyl chloride
and now it's free for them
is that not something we should consider
what if some of the people in this town
were like honey I'm going out against
monochloride I'll be back a little bit
and then they're like oh my God
the Lucky Charms truck has uh toppled
over and we're knee-deep and
marshmallows thank Christ because now
it's so I I think there's many things to
consider here now what is Trump saying
about this is he uh what's he what's he
up to
he was there speaking about
Palestine and to the nearby communities
in Ohio and Pennsylvania
we have told you loud and clear you are
not forgotten you are not forgotten we
stand with you we pray for you we'll
stay with you and your fight to help
answer mayor can you make the
accountability
accountability it'll all be out there no
way clearly is that the mayor that's the
mayor you want to hear a clip of him
talking I need to hear a clip of him
this man is amazing yeah he was saying I
want to hear the mayor
I want to hear the goddamn mayor
who's wearing a purple shirt from DXL
something I would buy
this man is wearing similar fashion to
me
he's more welcome to come if he wants to
come uh I was very frustrated last night
if you're talking about the comments I
made last night I was very frustrated
and you know I stand by those comments
but
um yeah if he wants to come
he's welcome
I like this man I like that he's in a
DXL shirt I like that he is out there
defending his town we hope we wish the
best for everybody in uh in Palestine
Ohio of course we have fans there should
we do a show there should we do a
benefit show I'm not even kidding should
we do a comedy show
to benefit the residents of East
Palestine stanstan Ohio
from New York City
because even though I don't fear the
chemicals and I think everything's
completely fine and I think these people
are just complaining over nothing just
some routine uh leprosy
um I feel comfortable if we could do a
benefit show for the residents of East
Palestine Ohio
from Maine
the rocky coast of Maine or you know in
the uh you know potentially in Irvine
California
but we should do I I literally I'm not
kidding
we should do a benefit show for these
people I don't know where the what the
money will be used for but
I would like to do a benefit show maybe
From Another Part of Ohio because I
don't think they have a venue for it
there
I don't know or maybe they do should I
go to East Palestine Ohio
to do a benefit show because these
people need stuff and you know here's
what I think we could do with the money
that we raised we could buy more of the
vinyl chloride they lost
if we borrow more of the chemical that
they lost
is it not a successful endeavor
East Palestine Community Theater where
we sell real tickets that's not going to
be good I wanna I want a big big big
[__] theater
uh to benefit the people you do Dayton
and he's Palestine Ohio I I think it's
the right thing to do and I'd like to do
it stay tuned for that by the way stay
tuned for
the benefit show are being announced in
East Palestine uh Ohio I would like I
genuinely want to do one and I want to
see how I can do what I think that
could actually be really great
I'm telling you right now everybody's
using expressvpn because all of these
private companies in the government
they're all spying on you selling your
information it's not right when you use
expressvpn your internet connection is
rerouted to a secure encrypted service
so that you can surf the web anonymously
without anyone looking over your
shoulder look I know you probably think
all you have to do is go into incognito
mode but that doesn't do it you're wrong
you need to use
expressvpn protect your privacy today
and get three months of expressvpn for
free wait a minute what three months for
free
visit expressvpn.com Tim Dillon that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com Tim Dillon you get
three months 90 days for free with a one
year package that's amazing you're only
paying for seven months again
expressvpn.com Tim Dillon this is the
service that everybody is using to keep
themselves safe from online Pirates big
Tech the big government the The
Berenstein Bears uh the devil everyone
who will come and get you this is what
you want to be kept safe from that's e x
p r e s vpn.com Tim Dylan three months
free
you're trying to ship some tranq dope
don't do that but if you are
doing a lot of online e-commerce and who
isn't you're going to need to really
focus on the front office stuff and what
does that mean well the origination
getting new clients being creative
developing new kinds of marketing
strategies what you don't need to worry
about is the back office the shipping
keeping track of orders making sure
everything's been delivered and
everybody's happy well then how do I do
that how about ship station okay ship
station works with all the big carriers
they work with everybody every single
person they're comparing rates making
sure you get the best they effortlessly
integrate everywhere you sell online
Amazon Etsy eBay Shopify and more you
manage every order from one simple
dashboard you automate routine shipping
tasks print shipping labels easily
compare rates and delivery times to
optimize every shipment it allows you to
have a fully functioning back office
where you are not
doing anything that takes away from your
origination of business which is the
most important thing to do keep growing
your business all year with ship station
use promo code Tim Dillon today at
shipstation.com to sign up for your free
60-day trial that's ship ship station
sta
t-i-o-n
ship station it's a hard word station
you don't spell it often shipstation.com
promo code Tim Dillon shipstation.com
promo code Tim Dylan
we're talking about tranq today folks
trank this is not an ad trank is a
Veterinary drug and it's worsening the
fentanyl crisis uh and I was watching uh
TV in Arizona local news and they were
talking about tranq dope this is what
everybody's on now all the kids because
fentanyl is I guess fun for a little
while until you realize there's harder
[__] out there there's actually harder
stuff than fennel you know the horrors
of the world are unfolding now so
quickly
um uh you know all of the nightmares
right the the the chemical explosions
and the economic inequality in Sam Smith
you can't fentanyl won't do it you have
to actually do something harder and the
tranq dope is what will uh get you to
where you need to go because the
fentanyl high is not enough to escape
the nightmare you need uh xylazine
authorized for Animals it's this event
drug is one ingredient that an
increasingly toxic brew of illicit drugs
this started with bath salts
um you know where it was like the the
things about bath salts were like like
the the headlines were insane it was
like a a woman ate a pit bulls oh there
was one headline where a woman strangled
a pit bull to death on bath salts or a
man ate another man's face on bath salts
like it was unbelievable like the
behavior the behavior that people
exhibited when they were on bath salts
yeah I mean it's like the attacker Rudy
Eugene was shot dead by police who
pleaded with him to stop
but only growls in response so this is
like a zombie in Miami this is from bath
salts uh he's eating another man's face
the police are like stop it and he just
went ah so that's you know nobody's
exhibited that type of behavior the bath
salts now we have uh tranctope and tranq
is like this homemade Brew this
concoction of drugs to really really get
you to the point where you're kind of a
zombie
dealers May mix xylazine into fentanyl
to save money federal law enforcement
Authority said the drug known as trank
among some users can be purchased at low
prices from Chinese suppliers and offset
uh an offset some of the opioid in the
mix
and offset some of the opioid in the mix
is presence in the drug Supply is part
of the arms race between criminals
seeking to enhance their products and
authorities trying to disrupt the market
so basically people are like throw a
little trank in there get a little trunk
wet your beak wet your whistle and if
you like it you can come back
um so what this is doing to people is
it's zombifying bodies so they're you're
seeing severe wounds uh they appear when
users in where users inject drugs and on
other parts of the body they start as
like blisters purple or white they're
encircled by red rings it becomes like
lesions
um they look like burn victims some
people have legs amputated I mean I mean
it's really it's zombifying people's
bodies
um there's a 28 year old Nathan Clark
long time opioid user despite the toll
xylazine is exacting on his body Mr
Clarkson he can't stop using it as part
of his regular drug consumption not
taking it would send him into brutal
withdrawal the xylazine is tearing me
apart he said I don't have skin on the
top of my hands you can see my tendons
you can see my bones so this is uh
the new hot drug on the street tranq
dope and people are taking it even
though they no longer have skin on their
hands they have tendon hands
and there you can just see their tendons
the way that you would do be like a
health book you would just see skeletal
hands and people are going I'm still
they still got to do it because if not
what does this do for animals like what
kind of what is this this xylazine like
it's it's it's utilized or it's
authorized most often and utilized for
animals for cats or dogs or something
um they use it on horses oh they use it
on all the good [__] gets used on horses
all the stuff that you know can really
take you there can get you there do we
have a YouTube is there anyone on tranq
dope that we can like look at is there
any type of exhibit a we can point to
and say if because we want to make sure
that you guys know who's on track dope
in your life right so
um if your son or daughter is sitting at
the table with you you want to make sure
that you have all well number one if
your son sits down or daughter and they
don't have skin on the top of their
hands this is a big
um indicator that they're on track dope
truly so if you're sitting there and
they're like oh it's just a friend you
know just hang up Mark you go hey
show me your hands
show me your hands why
just show them to me you never trust
anything I say
show me your skinless hands do your
hands have skin on them yeah they do I
promise show them to me why don't you
trust me that my hands have skin show me
your hands and then they just take their
skinless skin
and then you go drag top
so you have to make sure that your kids
are not on track dope
let's see what else you can look for
you underneath so this is like getting
bit by a brown recluse spider your skin
becomes necrotic meaning that it dies
the skin cells die and it gets hard you
can knock on it like but that's a leg
a leg
drug in modern history any worse tonight
we have the answer trank drug users
turned into real life zombies right down
to the rotten flesh we didn't want to
believe it either but it is real and it
is here all documented in this I love
the news voice when they're delivering
this they're like there's zombies
running around America it seems like
it's a bad movie but it's real and it's
here
the trunk dope is real and it's here
threat of xylazine mixing with illicit
drugs xylazine is an animal tranquilizer
tranq is what you get when you mix it
with fentanyl lab hits for xylazine are
up 112 percent in the west deaths are
rising two into the triple digits
xylazine has been confirmed in overdose
deaths in Snohomish and King counties at
least 12 that we know of and those most
familiar with the drug fear it will get
much worse he didn't have a flesh eating
disorder he didn't have an abscess and
he doesn't know how his finger went
missing and to me that is just by the
way she also looks horrible I mean let's
be very honest this woman looks horrific
she looks like she's on track dope she's
got Tourette's this is a social worker
this woman appears to be on TR if you
showed me that I would say two words
tranq dope drank dope
she's on track how do I trust her when
she's on track how bad is it out there
now that people just can't even smoke
crack anymore that doesn't do it for
them they're like crack won't even work
anymore I need trank let's see what this
the rest of this track head has to say
I said it was just miraculously gone
a narcotic nightmare one young lady was
telling me about it and uh she was
saying that she used it and then was out
and didn't remember anything moving like
a chameleon through an already Dangerous
Drug Supply that scared her enough to
want to go to detox as if fentanyl
wasn't deadly enough suppliers are
mixing your children will move like
chameleon through your home
looking for tracked up with their
necrotic dead skin lesions giving you a
clue that they're on the new hot street
drug track they seem everyone seems to
kind of know what tranq dope is Rochelle
long is a mental health professional
she's like listen I use track
occasionally just this month I can do it
responsible and Clinics to brace
themselves for the full-on arrival of
tranq tranq is short for tranquilizer in
this case xylazine you're strong enough
for big animals like horses when it's
mixed with fentanyl it gives users a
brand new kind of High they'll think
they start dancing and they they seem
kind of happy and they're just having
fun sounds great to an immediate like
zombie like trance staring through you
as if like a horror film
it starts out you're like it looks like
what [__] and then it's like
I'm jambe yeah I mean listen I don't I'm
not I don't really tell people what to
do to have fun because like I think
people need to figure that out on their
on their own
um
with something like tranq I will say
that the downsides of the drug
potentially May outweigh some of the
positives
like the dancing and the Euphoria I do
think that there is a chance that the
downsides of tranq
are going to
potentially
on the scales outweigh the good but I
leave it up to you I leave it up to you
out there if you want to use it if you
are a user of tranq
um and you want to come on the show like
via
like Zoom or something you know we're
not you're not coming near the studio
but if you are on track and there's a
way to get you to just tell us what it's
like I'm for that
you know that seems to make sense thank
you for listening everybody uh
timdalacomedy.com for live tickets and
we will see you on patreon and we'll see
you next week